wir präsentieren hier den flughafen
berlin brandenburg bzw die
flughafengesellschaft ein scheißjob
[Musik]
unser land darf endlich wieder stolz
sein auf die deutsche rüstungsindustrie
unerschrocken beglücken wir die welt mit
unserer nachhaltigen waffentechnik
leider noch nicht mit ökosiegel aber mit
dem testurteil sehr gut
[Musik]
das was die kleine bombe die ihr denkmal
die werte zwischen 20 und 30
30.000 mit dem lenksystem noch ist ja
schon schade dafür dass man zweimal
benutzen kann
da bist du
zu verdienen
mich noch viel spaß die beiden
schätzchen durchfährt so einen
frauenkörper ein wohliger schauer wenn
man in so ein ding sitzt so ein beben
das ist schon mal kein problem ja es gut
aber es ist auf jeden fall sehr aufreger
und wenn man da vorne drauf drücken
würde dann wird es uns machen und hätte
man ein paar leute weg kostet geld
das überlasse ich lieber anderen macht
ihr da findet mich scheiße
auch der reporter nach vielen jahren
noch ein pazifistisch verdorbener wer
kopf zeigt sich von den technischen
neuerungen der rüstungsindustrie
begeistert leider kann man jetzt nur
losfliegen weil das runtergemacht schöne
meine sache dass sich medien gemacht
habe
jugendsünde dafür läuft anderswo das
geschäft super auch mit kuscheligen
drittstaaten wie zuverlässiges der
saudische kunde
wir können nur positives berichten läuft
sehr gut wir haben hier auch man
verträge abgeschlossen
es gibt ja durchaus auch diskussion das
ist dass man sagt so an die sollte man
nichts liefern wie sehen sie das
auch hier muss ich leider an unserer
stelle verweisen kann ich keine aussage
pressesprecherin iris sie gerade ach so
okay ich bin nicht autorisiert vor
laufender kamera zu hallo wir machen ja
der gemeine rüstungsfabrik ahnt ist eher
ein scheues reh ist die hatz von
friedens chaoten auf in daran schuld
tatsache keiner bekennt mehr ich bin
gerne waffenhändler machen können und
wir machen dokumentation jemand
dokumentation wurde in der aktive
elektronische zum beispiel für die neue
app von 125 afrika die jetzt im bau ist
ja und davor halt eben für den
einsatzgruppenversorger
versorgungsschiff der marine
aber sind sie manchmal nicht auch
erschüttert über die hubs die b21
stattfindet oder auf
menschen lassen dieses jahr bitte lasst
uns hier abbrechen weil er einfach
abbrechen möchte darf ich diese frage
stellen dürfte stelle muss aber nein
beantworten vielen dank
den herren hier gefragt während sein
chef hasst uns gibt es druck verstehen
aber die messe zeigt auch die härtesten
und schmutzigsten kampfeinsätze finden
manchmal sogar im inland statt hallo sie
sind vor für den flughafen berlin
brandenburg bzw
die flughafengesellschaft ein scheißjob
ne
den will ich heute die haben
[Applaus]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
ein leichter last ich hab die schnauze
voll
loslassen abo da